straight ahead on law and crime daily
britney spears wants her conservatorship
to end no more brittany
being spoken for no more brittany wants
the pop icon telling a judge she wants
her life back
and shocking photographs a 13 year old
saw of his own father
before the teen was murdered his brother
breaking down on the witness stand
i spent a lot of time with dylan and
i helped him a lot plus how much time
will derek chauvin spend behind bars
we asked george floyd's family attorney
ben crump
we've always wanted equal justice and
the former saturday night live cast
member
taking the stand in the robert durst
trial the alleged alibi
now revealed if she loved you you know
it was like a juggernaut of love law and
crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm brian ross
in for brian buckmeyer on assignment in
minneapolis for the sentencing of derek
shoven and with me here in new york is
co-host terry austin
and we begin with britney spears
speaking out in a los
angeles courtroom and telling the judge
the conservatorship she's been living
under for years
has been abusive and she wants it to end
long crimes anjanet levy is here with
more on the dramatic hearing
and what spears fans are saying about it
all and jeanette
britney spears spoke to the court for 24
minutes in an impassioned plea she said
she's been forced to use birth control
and she told the judge i want my life
back
what do we want when do we want it
it's a day britney spears and her fans
have been anticipating for some time
spears speaking directly to the judge
in her conservatorship case brittany
telling her truth
britney finally speaking no more
brittany
being spoken for no more brittany wants
spears described to the court what her
life has been like over the years
she said she's not been happy and feels
as if she's been working and paying
people who tell her
how she can live controlling her every
move
spears even revealed she was forced to
take lithium
when her therapists and handlers felt
she wasn't being cooperative
when she said that her family was 100
you know controlling her due to
giving her lithium that was a shocker
also a shock spear said she was not
aware that she could petition the court
to end the conservatorship
or hire her own lawyer she has been
represented by a lawyer appointed by the
court
and she wants to have another child
something her conservators are not
allowing her to do
we finally heard what we've been hearing
rumors
speculations allegations we finally got
the truth
law and crime producer jordan chacon
watched the proceedings
the main thing that she wanted to tell
us all
because we've been waiting for so long
is that in 2019 she wasn't honest with
us and she lied
and she was basically saying you know i
had to fake it until i made it um she
thought that you know her pretending to
be happy
was going to be you know something where
she can actually transition into
happiness
but spears is not happy and wants to
live her own life
not as a slave to others her fans
backing her
all the way
britney spears told the court that her
father and anyone else involved in this
conservatorship
should be in jail for hurting her and
punishing her that's exactly how she
feels
jamie spears his lawyer later said that
he he is sorry to see his daughter
suffering this way
and the judge thanked britney spears for
speaking to the court and said she knew
that it took
courage for her to do so she said she's
also looking forward to reading
future court documents that are filed in
the case brian
thanks angenet well terry austin now
that we've heard these specific details
sounds like a nightmare
directly from brittany you think she
might finally be able to get out of
the conservatorship and get back control
of her personal life
well let's hope so brian i actually
understand
why her fans are so sympathetic for the
past 13 years she's been
under this conservatorship and she's
managed to perform she's managed to
get all of this money and she is
literally paying
all of the people around her and the
estate so
i think if she can manage her own career
and perform she should be able to
manage her personal life as well other
people
are in conservative ships and don't last
for that long
and anjanette levy these details really
do sound like a nightmare situation for
her
and they point to the larger issues of
this issue of a conservatorship system
in general
yeah i think that's right brian and she
actually said that she hasn't even been
able to go get her nails done or use her
own credit card so
the things that she said in court were
incredibly disturbing to hear that a
39 year old woman's being treated this
way and she
and some of her fans her fans in
particular were saying outside of the
courthouse
yesterday that this points to a larger
issue
about the probate system the
conservatorship system they say it's
really impossible to get out of these
it's very difficult to get out of them
once they begin
and these are really meant for people
who cannot make their own decisions for
themselves
and terry very quickly if it can happen
to a rock star worth millions it
probably could happen to anybody
that's right it makes us think that we
have to look at this system so that
people aren't under
the control of others for so very long
when they could control their own
affairs
absolutely terry austin anderson levy
thank you very much turning now to more
top legal news making headlines rudy
giuliani has been suspended
from practicing law at new york state
over false election fraud claims
a court is immediately suspending the
former new york city mayor's law license
due to his work as a counsel to former
president donald trump
the court said giuliani made
demonstrably false and misleading
statements to the court
and to the public over voter fraud
during the 2020 presidential election
giuliani will have an opportunity for
reinstatement
anti-virus software creator john mcafee
has died
mcafee was in a spanish prison awaiting
extradition to the united states for tax
evasion charges
prosecutors say the department of
justice brought
cases against him and accused mcafee of
defrauding investors of more than
13 million dollars through false and
misleading
cryptocurrency his cause of death in
spain is under investigation
but officials there say everything
indicates suicide
still ahead on law and crime daily we
preview the sentencing of former cop
derrick shoven but first a brother's
anguish
but the son of mark redwine had to say
about his relationship with his father
and with his younger brother dylan who
redwine is now accused of murdering
welcome back turning now to salacious
testimony in the mark redwine trial
he's accused of murdering his son dylan
his other son corey testified
that dylan found disgusting photos of
their father
we just had a very strong and tight-knit
relationship
corey redwine says he and his younger
brother dylan were not just brothers but
friends as well corey would later act as
a father figure
in dylan's life dylan needed someone to
take him to practice
to play catch with him to
take him shopping to talk about girls
with him
their parents separated in 2005 divorced
about five years later
and the brothers lived primarily with
their mother corey described a trip they
took with their father
mark redwine to cleveland on father's
day 2011.
mark was asleep in their hotel room when
corey says
dylan found compromising photos of their
father
on his laptop he found pictures of mark
dressed in women's clothing wearing
a diaper taking
selfies of him wearing the clothing
wearing the diaper eating the feces that
was in the diaper
corey grabbed his phone and took
pictures of what he saw
more than a year later dylan was on a
baseball trip to boston with mark
and asked corey seven times to send him
the photos
but corey refused because he
had wanted to show mark
what he had discovered himself i
was just worried about where dylan was
and i didn't want
any more confrontation um with dylan
being as upset as he was in sending
those messages
i didn't really want to send something
more to
a bigger fire on thanksgiving weekend
dylan was visiting his father
and disappeared corey says he was upset
because
mark refused to help during the search
which was just eight miles down the road
from mark's house the following year
investigators found dylan's remains
and ruled his death a homicide a grand
jury indicted mark for second-degree
murder
on cross-examination corey admitted he
eventually sent those photos to mark
he said you are what you eat look in the
mirror right
yes hold on to quote yes
told him he was a coward correct yes
called him
eater right yes mark replied asking
corey
why cory would want to hurt dylan
anymore on redirect
prosecutors asked corey how he feels
about his father
i still love him i
i
i wish i didn't have to be here
family tragedy terry it must be so
difficult for son to testify
against his father how do you think
corey's holding up under this
brian it's got to be extremely difficult
but i think corey is holding up
very well he was able to give facts and
figures
he was able to give dates and places so
he definitely
established the case for the prosecution
but you notice there when he's talking
about
family and relationships he does get
emotional when he's talking about his
brother
he was actually more like a father to
dylan so
he definitely was very close to dylan so
that was very hard for him
and it was even hard for him when it
came to his father because obviously a
parent is
always a parent one thing i will notice
here is the fact that
corey never said my father he kept
saying
mark or he said mark redwine so i
thought that was interesting
absolutely angenet how do you think the
defense is going to handle all this this
compelling testimony
well you know it's certainly difficult
and those photos are something once you
see them you
don't unsee them they have objected the
defense objected to the admission of
those photos obviously they
they don't want the jury to see that but
they've also objected to even the use of
the phrase murder when referring to
dylan's death
they've suggested that animals may have
done something to dylan that he may have
been abducted or harmed by someone else
so i think they're just trying to
strategically
pick some places where they can you know
pull it a thread
and raise some doubt in the
prosecution's case
and terry finally i guess it really is
in the end a circumstantial evidence
case in terms of who killed him
absolutely there's no real direct proof
so hopefully the circumstances will
bear the truth all right coming up on
law and crime daily a former saturday
night live star
takes the stand in the robert durst
trial
plus what george floyd's family attorney
is hoping for in the upcoming sentencing
of derrick sheldon
we look into how judge peter cahill will
make his decision
that's next
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin is set to learn how much time
he'll spend behind bars for the murder
of george floyd
a jury convicted chauvin of
second-degree murder third degree murder
and second-degree manslaughter in court
documents
prosecutors are asking judge peter
cahill to sentence him
to 30 years behind bars his defense is
requesting
time served and probation attorney ben
crump represents the floyd family and
says
there's a simple equation for how much
time they believe chauvin should serve
whatever sentence george floyd would
have received had the rose being
reversed
and george floyd put his knee on derek
jovan's neck
for nine minutes and 29 seconds while he
begged for his life
well then that's the same sentence that
derek shoving should receive
it has always been about equal justice
for us
because we are trying to send the
message
that all marginalized minorities in
america want
the only thing black people want in
america
is equal justice under the law
terry austin do you think it's likely
shelvin will make a statement before the
judge and the sentencing tomorrow
you know i think it's a distinct
possibility brian and i think it would
be to his advantage
throughout the entire trial we saw him
sitting there and he was very stoic
he was very you know straight very
little emotion
so i think if he takes the stand it'll
give the jury to see
who he really is underneath that mask
and it'll give him an opportunity
to express some remorse and i think that
would help
as far as the whole sentencing is
concerned and
finally brian i think it's going to give
him a chance to explain
why he thought his actions were
necessary i think that's going to be
very difficult
i mean 9 minutes 29 seconds that length
of time is
way too long obviously and it resulted
in the death of george floyd
but i think at least he can give some
sort of explanation
and jeanette levy you were there for the
verdict and as terry was saying derek
shoveling didn't seem to show much
emotion or any emotion during the trial
after he was found guilty
it still will be a very tense moment for
him now as he's leading to learn how
much of the rest of his life he'll spend
behind bars
yeah and it could be much of the rest of
his life that he'll spend behind bars i
guess we'll find out tomorrow but he
just had a flat affect
throughout the entire trial throughout
the entire case and i think when the
jury came back
so quickly relatively quickly if you
look at how much
evidence was presented he probably knew
that
it was going to be a guilty verdict and
you know this was a case that
the evidence was out there before the
trial even started for
almost a year so there was a lot of
publicity around this a lot of emotions
so
i don't think it was a surprise when the
jury came back after five or six hours
of deliberation and found him guilty on
all of those counts that couldn't have
been a shock to him
and terry under a minnesota sentencing
guidelines for someone who does not have
a criminal record like derek shovin the
guidelines call for about a 12 and a
half year sentence but here prosecutors
asking for much more
what's their basis for that well they're
saying
obviously the judge did find that there
were aggravating factors not the least
of which was the
fact that there were children present
during this
whole incident and i think the
prosecution is looking at all of those
aggravating factors
and saying to the judge look we think
that you should give him more
more time all right thank you so much
now to florida where a manhunt is
underway for a suspect accused
of shooting a daytona beach officer in
the head
police say the officer is in critical
condition the department released the
officer's body cam video
from 9 p.m on wednesday the officer was
investigating a suspicious vehicle when
the driver got
out and a scuffle ensued the daytona
police
chief says the driver shot the officer
then took off
officers searched a nearby apartment and
reported finding
bulletproof vests guns and ammunition
the suspect has been identified
as 29 year old although wallace a 100
000
reward is being offered for information
leading to his capture
and arrest when we come back the latest
in the robert durst
trial what forensic evidence reveals
about the gun used to shoot surgeon
berman
and what she confided to a close friend
about her good friend
bobby durst
[Music]
and welcome back continuing coverage of
the trial of millionaire real estate
developer robert durst
where detectives say they still don't
have the murder weapon
durst is accused of shooting his best
friend susan berman in december 2000.
in court defense attorney dick de guerin
brought out the 22-caliber gun durst has
admitted he used to shoot his texas
neighbor morris black
durst also admits to owning a nine
millimeter gun the same type of weapon
believed to have been used to shoot
susan berman but on cross-examination
a now retired detective confirmed that
durst gun was not the same gun
that killed susan berman
nine millimeter that he was arrested
with and the shell
and you got it compared by a ballistics
expert
right yes and the result
was that gun was not the gun that fired
that bullet
there's no evidence that that gun was
the gun that fired that bullet
he wrote it up as inconclusive in
pasadena
right and you've tested it since then
haven't you i had gary jones fly the gun
out here to los angeles where we had it
tested by our firearms
by your own people and it was negative
wasn't it correct yes
okay next up on the witness stand was
lorraine newman a familiar name a close
friend of susan berman
and newman was one of the original cast
members of saturday night live
she's best known for her character
connie conehead
however there's nothing funny when she
testified that susan berman
confided in her that she had provided an
alibi for durst
when durst's wife disappeared
susan told me that she had provided an
alibi for her
for him for bobby do you specifically to
the best your memory recall
susan telling you that she had made a
phone call for bob
yes if i would ask you
um how certain are you not regarding the
time
but how certain are you that susan said
to you
that she had provided bob with an alibi
what would your response be 100
so terry austin if there's no murder
weapon in this case how's the
prosecution
prosecution going to prove that durst
was the killer
you know it's really hard when you don't
have the smoking gun so to speak
and you only have circumstantial
evidence and that's exactly what we have
here we don't have a weapon
nothing that durst might have had
matched what the
bullet was to susan berman so that's not
going to help the prosecution
i do think though that the
circumstantial evidence is
quite sufficient here we have the
cadaver note
and anyone who writes a note like this
and durst even said anyone who writes
a note like this is the killer and he
has now
admitted to writing that note so i think
that that is in the prosecution's pocket
and i also think that we've placed him
in los angeles during
this crime we know for a fact that emily
altman said
that he was there and others have placed
him there so i think the prosecution is
going to be able to
establish that juris did it they've
taken quite a bit time already still
another five or six
weeks for the prosecution at this point
terry are they making a compelling
argument are they
overproving the case you know i do
think lewin and the prosecution team in
general they have made compelling
arguments and i think the jury is
probably convinced
at this point the real question is
whether or not
lewin is getting on the nerves of the
jury because
each and every witness takes so long for
every point and lewin continues to
pressure them to
admit certain things so i think on the
one hand
he's gotten all the facts in and he's
done that really methodically and i
think that has
worked well all right terry austin thank
you so much for being here and thank you
all for joining us here
on law and prime daily we'll see you
next time as we continue to discuss
justice in america i'm brian ross thanks
for joining us
[Music]
you